Ngày tư nhấn ngày đầu năm, họ đậu sất khẩu lông sản khi nhận nhiều tiến điều tích cực khi lượng đơn hàng sôi dào.
Tại các quý trọc điểm, dân nghiệp và người dân vừa thích bật đón tét vừa tập trù sản sất để kiến độ sào hàng.
Như dân nghiệp cho biết, đơn hàng sức khẩu trong quy một đã được ký kế thỏa tất.
Hãy nay các lương vị đang đẩy mạnh thu hoạch và đón coi các mặt hàng sâu của vụ đông sân như bắp cải,
gà sớt, đề phục vụ thị trường. Theo dân nghiệp, sớd lượng đơn hàng tăng mạnh,
dân mặt hàng tăng sốt đã đạt tới tắm người của trong cộ tài lưu. Tạo khi vọng tăng trường cao trong năm 2020.
Bộ nước nghiệp và môi trường cho biết, dụ năm 2020 sử báo còn nhiều khó khăn,
tòan ngành vẫn đặt một tiêu đặt từ bệ巴 đến bày tư tiếu với đề kìm nèc sức khẩu lúc sản.
Các sảy pháp mở cửa thị trường đã giảng hóa thị trường sức khẩu, đặc biệt là thị trường A0,
dụ con nhiều thách thức phía trước, những tiến hiệu đơn hàng tích cực ngày từ đầu năm cho thế nhiều cầu thị trường vẫn giọc mở đối với nước sản Việt Nam.